hello everyone how's everybody doing
hope you're doing fine we got another
little lecture a little class today I'll
be doing with fellow we left behind uh
what is it about a week ago mr. st.
Thomas Aquinas and I'm gonna read
baptize him I'm gonna call him st.
Thomas a quadrant he was the inventor of
quantum as we will see today before I
get to that I'm gonna be answering some
questions some common said that some
people have made anyone before they I
want to make sure people understand that
we're going to lose sockeye Zambia we're
gonna have our eighth rational physics
conference over there
we've already did what Europe North
America went to Mexico South America
we're in Argentina
here in Europe we had a couple in
England and here in Germany and we
haven't had any in the east so we just
need to get someone over there to host
it but right now we're gonna be doing it
in Lusaka fighting with hyenas and lions
who knows what ok so just be aware 4th
of April that's a Saturday you see if
you can get there several flights going
from Europe to Africa typically through
Addis Abeba or well some other countries
and cities anyways let's get on with the
questions today we've got a first
comment it's got to do with extinction
and I'm just gonna deal with one comment
on extinction today ok and what's the
issue the issue is that you know I have
a theory and so and it goes that humans
are about to become extinct we're the
last generation of humans and one of the
questions pops up is you know what do
you mean by a generation are you saying
me are you saying my grandson I mean you
know you may be born in the same century
like you know take as an example galley
fail he died when Newton was born and
the question is were they of the same
generation when they never got to know
each other like personally you know and
yeah a generation is a very broad term
very undefined term it just gives you an
idea that it's all the people around the
same period of time that's about it and
so there's you know there's no
scientific way of putting it in those
terms in precise terms when I say that
if we're the last generation I'm saying
it's imminent it's gonna happen maybe
after I die me it's gonna happen before
I die
it can happen anytime that's that's the
notion that I have now this person asked
let us assume extinction is going to
happen 40 years from now okay what does
it matter to me by that time I probably
is dead okay and long gone it is the
next generation who will suffer on the
other hand if it is going to happen in
ten years in all probabilities I will be
there is that better to know that one is
going to die naturally than knowing that
I'm going to be killed and eaten by my
fellow humans who are my friends and
relatives isn't it isn't a time frame
and essential part yeah obviously people
want to know if if extinction is
imminent people want to know if they're
part of that imminence okay the you know
is it gonna happen after I die I don't
care right well maybe you do care if you
have kids you know I have a three boys
and big boys now and you would think
that or you would like for them to do
their normal lies you know to old age
and so on and I don't think it's going
to happen for them and so for me it's a
concern because you know I love my kids
and so knowing or having this feeling
that you're the last generation that
your kids are not gonna see retirement
age you know well I don't know if it
affects everybody in the same way of
course if you don't have kids it may not
affect you it does affect me okay
so yeah knowing whether it's gonna
happen sooner or later sooner or later
is important but you know well I'll
answer that in a second here says
irrespective what everyone says people
are more interested in knowing what
happens to you know oneself okay as you
rightly said people always think
extinction happens to another generation
not one's own yeah that's that's through
every bit all the movies they're all in
the future they all happen to year 3000
okay and even fact they never end in
extinction they always have a baby at
the end and that's you know the the
thing starts all over again
how long will I live and how will I die
isn't what everyone is asking it isn't
what everyone's asking all the comments
denying the theory aren't they telling
their hope that they are not going to be
part of the extinction you are
predicting for this generation and so
here's my reply to that put it on a side
by side well I'm not an astrologer you
know I cannot tell you when it's gonna
happen I can't tell it's gonna happen on
the first of May of the year 2030 you
know I can't tell you that and not even
God can tell you that and the fact that
I cannot predict the exact day of the
extinction does not invalidate the
theory the mechanism of extinction you
know times we don't deal with
predictions like they do in mathematical
physics and science we deal with
explanation we have to explain a
mechanism and the mechanism of mass
extinction has to do with the theorists
disappearance of a food chain and not
with what you read about you know out
there in the literature or in blogs and
whatever saying that it was doing the
catastrophic accidents you know acts of
God and he doesn't like the food theory
he has to explain you know past
extinctions that's the starting point
past mass extinctions occurred because
of food the ecological pyramid
overturned that's that's the theory so
you know I'm saying that we're gonna die
in the humans are gonna die in a mass
extinction it's gonna happen soon and
it's going to happen because of food we
already have
the reason the the cause and the
mechanism and if you don't like that I
will start by telling me how animals in
the past died and hopefully you can
explain the the only thing that an
extinction Theory has to explain which
is selectivity yeah okay the only other
thing I want to say there is that you
know in general my my idea why it's
gonna be so imminent and why the global
economy is going to crash one of the one
of the features I looked at or one of
the things I look at is China China is
the motor of the planet it's been so for
maybe the last 20 25 years China was way
backwards you know and grew started
growing and became an economic
powerhouse you have to remember in the
60s China did not exist essentially it
was such a poor country and it was so
underdeveloped that for all practical
purposes there was no such thing as
China it was not part of the global
market in any significant way and when
Nixon went to see Deng Xiaoping over
there in what was it 75 or thereabouts
that's when the United States started
selling things and the Europeans started
selling things to China China became a
manufacturing powerhouse stole all the
manufacturing from the West the West you
know around the 80s began time to Reagan
began to grow as a service economy in
Europe as well and Japanese Japan as
well they went from manufacturing to
services and China that remained with
all the manufacturing okay because it
was cheaper to manufacture stuff there
even by you know multinationals and now
you know if you look at the chart see if
I get it here here you see the chart you
can see that China now about a few years
ago services have surpassed
manufacturing and services going to take
over China China's
become a service economy and as it does
it's not gonna grow as much as it's been
growing lately and here you can see
another little graph see if I can get it
up here put it over here last three
years saw an article recently last three
years the sales of Commerce in China has
gone down and this year is predicted to
go even further down I think you're
gonna lose like two percent of sales in
other words what has happened the
Chinese economy is becoming saturated
can't come it can't continue growing at
25 percent like it was like 20 25 years
ago today is growing at 5% only and
tomorrow it's going to be growing at 4 3
2 1
when China not if but when China starts
growing at a slower rate there's it's
gonna be a bottleneck for United States
for Europe for Japan and other countries
that sell to China and buy from China so
the global economy is gonna start
growing slower and slower and slower
until it grows no more there's gonna be
zero economic growth on the planet and
people will have this idea you know
we've always grown
yeah we've always grown and we are in
new in a new age now our age today is
that we don't grow anymore first we
don't grow exponentially anymore like in
the 19th century and now we're you know
it's becoming concave the curve is
flattening out and some point will reach
zero growth and when that happens not if
but when it happens the whole global
economy is going to be in trouble ok
companies are going to shut down they're
gonna kick people out into the streets
if you unemployment is going to grow
okay and nothing is gonna overrule the
no amount of money creation or debt
incurring debt by governments is going
to change that okay we're gonna reach a
point where a maximum growth for the
planet when that
happens we're all in trouble okay
because a lot of things are going to
happen at that point in time companies
are going to suffer there'll be more and
more mergers than what we see today in
fact lots of people in the streets more
unemployed looking for internet jobs
services you know some kind of thing
that you do and you know and there is
not room enough for everybody and you
might think there is but no so all I can
tell you this I look at these things
things like like these numbers here that
give me an idea that something is wrong
with the global economy anyways I think
it's you know I think the global economy
is going to collapse when it does then
at that point you know nobody produces
food there's no reason to produce food
and ship it to the cities because money
is no more okay that's the theory in a
nutshell anyways let's go with the next
one this has to do more with what we
discussed in the last couple day times
which is about the existence of God and
this is not a philosophical issue some
people say well that's philosophy no the
word exists belongs exclusively to
physics physics studies and tries to
explain that which exists and what
happened okay so if someone claims that
God exists or God doesn't exist or maybe
he exists that issue belongs to physics
falls into squarely within physics and
that involves location involves motion
all things related to physics not the
philosophy so this thing that was
creating the past by Aristotle
metaphysics ontology plays no part you
know that stuff stays and philosophy
whatever they do there we don't care
existence belongs to the physics you say
that a table exists you're talking about
physics you cross the line into physics
now we're talking physics and so that's
the issue that's the context for God for
the existence of God one fellow who
apparent
likes God a lot God is not a physical
object oh okay
thanks for time yeah because the Bible
says you know the Bible says that God
was a burning bush and the Bible says
that God you know his spirit floated of
the face of the waters and he uses the
word he right created us in His image so
I don't know how he cannot be a physical
object if an object is that which has
shape and God seems to meet that
specification okay God is not an
abstraction okay so he's not a he's not
enough stretching what is he then
there's only two possibilities okay but
but he is a being concrete whatever that
means however not in the ordinary sense
of that term concrete ok says he's not
like the concrete we put on on the floor
ok cement through whatever you will have
to forgive the narrowness of human
language here yeah I can see that
especially narrowness of your
explanation and God is that active force
if God is a force God is an abstraction
God is a concept ok so how do we answer
these things well here's my version side
by side ok so you can see it and God is
a word a word it has only two
possibilities and rationality object or
concept you cannot be both you cannot be
an object can be a concept ok an object
is that which has shape concept is a
word that invokes embodies two objects
or two words momentarily treated as
objects God cannot be both or neither
God is either an object or a constant
there is no third category of words for
the purposes of science it is up to the
naysayer to propose a third category and
defend his proposal so I mean we need to
be able to follow his his dissertation
when he says God exists or God is this
or God is not that we need to follow
what he's saying we so far this person
cannot make sense of his words because
he says God is not an object God is not
a concept that's what he's saying here
so what is God well then we need to know
what God is the proponent of God has to
choose whether his notion that were God
is one or
the other object or concept saying that
God is neither an object or an
abstractions attempt to elude punishment
in rationality Andean force is a concept
okay so yeah I don't know you got to
tell me what your what you think God is
and you can't say well if I knew God
wouldn't be so great with this would
answer that I received it's a way of
eluding some way of eluding the question
that's all it is you you have no answer
and that's why you're saying well God is
not that and God is not the other
whatever you say God is not okay tell me
what God is okay that's what you got you
gotta tell me I need to be able to
follow your reasoning okay if you have
any okay here's another comment I think
st. Paul God is real is a real spiritual
being
whatever that is right yeah he's a ghost
he's a magician
he's energy what is God you know that
exists in time and space uh-huh
both in an immanent and transcendent not
virtually present only but substantially
present okay
it cannot be that he is nowhere so he
told me he's God is not an object got it
not a concept he's not enough stretch I
don't know what God is but cannot be
that God is no where'd the notion that
God exists only outside of space and
time is false God exists in time and
space uh-huh
okay so how do we answer this let's
let's get to it
here you have my side by side all the
obstacles can be said to exist exist
means physical presence the physical
part invokes an object and the
president's part invokes location if God
is not an object God does not exist
pursuant to the definition of the word
exist okay
so God has to be an object to begin with
because that's the definition you don't
like the definition good the naysayer
has to define exists in order for the
crowd to follow his reasoning if God is
somewhere then God is an object God
cannot be somewhere not be an object
because what is in that
space in that place and whatever in that
location
God has location distance to every atom
in the universe naysayer has to provide
alternative definitions for these
keywords okay and so yeah you need to
define your terms so we can follow your
presentation and the important thing you
should know is no one in the last 10,000
years has been able to define the word
exists
that's why atheists and theists run
around in circles because no one has
defined the word exist neither atheist
nor theist and the only issue there is
you know if you if you don't like my
definition you define exists so we know
what you're talking about that's the
important word in the phrase or sentence
or whatever God exists when someone says
God exists God is important you got to
tell me whether God is an object or
concept but the important word is the
word exist
you got to know what the word exists
means and not a single atheist or theist
knows what the word exists means or
agnostic for that matter okay another
comment okay moving on here says if you
think you will be able to explain all
things through human language you are
deluding yourself you cannot even
explain to me how it is that you move
your hand okay this is how I move my
hand you will never be able to do so in
purely mechanistic language uh-huh when
you explain something mechanically you
are never really explaining it oh okay
so what am i doing that you are merely
explaining one layer of many more upon
within that thing okay in order to be
able to answer him we need to define
what we mean by the by an explanation
essentially and science is about
rational explain what is an explanation
or to explain we define it and that way
we know what we're saying when we use
the word explain making a movie so that
the viewers understand the mechanism
proposed that's for the purposes of
physics okay otherwise he's got to
define explain or explanation the
language of physics is not mathematics
the language of physics is Ellis
stray ssin I should be able to
illustrate a mechanism okay if you can
add illustrate your theory you are not
doing physics in science we explain one
mechanism at a time hee-hoo not a who
cannot explain a mechanism but insists
that God somehow created the universe is
delusional he's sharing his ignorance
with a crowd I mean you got to tell me
how God created the if you say that God
created the universe tell me the
mechanism don't tell me he did just tell
me what the mechanism is that then we
can follow then we can see what you have
in your head in your brain see for
example here's a here's an incident and
I'm gonna explain it in the way we do it
in physics which is with a movie if I
put in a movie and you watch the movie
and you can tell how something happened
you have explained it because you are
able to make a movie and all you need to
explain is one incident at a time you
don't have to explain iteration after
iteration after iteration right endless
endless uh you know explanations of
explanations of explanations that's not
science and science is explain one one
thing at a time okay and here we have a
good ol let see if I can get this bigger
here we have good ol Felix the Cat and I
want you to tell me if you can figure
out by watching this if you know how he
broke the window tell me how the window
broke that's all I want to know can you
did you figure it out do you need a more
time maybe you know to figure it out you
know this is simple make a movie of a
mechanism and we can tell you and you
will be able to explain that mechanism
someone asks you how did the window
break yeah I can explain it the window
broke because a magnet or a horseshoe
went through the window
very easy what part did you not
understand of my explanation so you know
this notion that he has that you know
you cannot explain anything
you know it's nonsense obviously you
know he he doesn't know what he's
talking about and I know if it was the
same thought but here it says I don't
believe God
this I know with absolute certainty that
God is that he is and my answer is
believe to believe knowledge to know
okay it's their equal the knowledge and
belief are synonyms
now that is defined still with plato's
definition which is justified true
belief so knowledge is believed anyone
who says he knows he's just telling you
what his belief is okay and what is
belief it's just personal opinion what
is a opinion religion so we don't care
about that at least here you know here
we only care about what you can explain
not what you believe okay
and so belief has nothing to do with
science now he says God endures forever
okay whatever forever is even through
time and is everywhere present in space
even in space so he's everywhere and
before he said he was outside of time
and space or with in time and space now
he's everywhere in time and spiller at
least in space right well if God is
everywhere present then the word God has
no meaning you've got is everything God
is nothing okay
and so to say to say that God is
everything God is everywhere and God is
throughout time you're not saying
anything all you're saying is just
babbling about something you cannot
explain in any rational term okay and so
yeah God is a synonym of nothing in this
context you know if God is everything
God is nothing as well
God is vacuum space empty space so if
God is everything you wanna make at
least a eliminate space vacuum because
otherwise we say hey God is also nothing
he's something and nothing at the same
time you know this kind of thing okay
here we have another comment this from
another fella and he once introduced God
through quantum mechanics okay it has to
show that just like in quantum mechanics
which has been proven right God is
everywhere and so he says God is
all-pervading God is everywhere it means
God is president each and every point of
the universe
equally present everywhere uh-huh
one cannot be distant from one's own
self that's why God is everywhere
because he is himself and God is
everything and everything is itself okay
that distance from any point of space to
each and every other point of space is
really zero okay we have zero distance
between two points why because they're
one and the same
that's essentially what he's saying
which is irrational either we have to or
we have one and he says we have two
points of space but they're at the same
place because the the the object that
contains those two points is one in this
case God but I like the next one he says
has already been confirmed by science
through the phenomenon of quantum
entanglement well the first thing we
have to realize that quantum
entanglement has not been proven quantum
entanglement is a word entanglement is a
word that is applied to an unknown
something the mathematicians have no
clue how to explain in rational terms so
they call it entanglement they say this
particle over here affects that one over
there that's called entanglement how it
does it the jury is still out they have
no idea how to explain that and in fact
this fellow references a in article and
here's the article very quickly right
and this article comes from quantum
magazine so I guess you know what
they're gonna talk about they're gonna
vouch for the irrationality of quantum
mechanics this quantum entanglement
a phenomenon in which particles were
points in a field such as the
electromagnetic field shed their
separate identities and assume a shared
existence with one another's in other
words they become one God everywhere
he's only one he's himself I am what I
am okay and so he says normally
physicists think of these correlations
as spanning space linking far-flung
locations but a growing body of research
is investigating how these correlations
can spend time as well what happens now
can be correlated with what happens
later in ways that
elude a simple mechanistic explanation
and there's the key they cannot explain
this I mean you know to say that that
this is what particles do that they
affect each other through time and
through space and to whatever
what what what these people are doing is
is eluding the main issue the main issue
is please explain the mechanism what is
the physical mechanism that's what a
physicist does you know a mathematician
you can you know he just says it does so
we measured this is what we observed how
can you observe if it's invisible well
this is what we detected you know
something affected something at a
distance and that's what we'll call
entanglement so they don't have an
explanation
so the to use the word entangle my new
to show that oh I know a lot about
quantum mechanics and science because I
can say the word entanglement no you
have to explain entanglement and not a
single so-called mathematical physicist
can explain it to this day
okay so here's a little picture that
they had in that article of entanglement
how you know they show that you're
painting the head of one bus there and
it shows up on the picture later
you know the again is this science or
what do we not call that I mean if you
think that's science and because the
so-called scientists proved it all over
the world and you just bought into it
well all you are is just drinking
kool-aid yeah you haven't explained it
explain to me how that happens I mean
Hollywood we can do a lot of stuff like
that is done you know but show me in a
lab let's go to 11:00 show me how you do
that same thing and of course you won't
be able to do that okay because it's
nonsense the physical interpretations of
quantum mechanics are nonsense okay
moving on here one fella
s or says what do you say to people who
regard mathematical objects as mere
instruments
well you know we don't have these things
in physics mathematical objects whatever
they are and here's my answer side by
side the mathematics mathematics has
nothing to do with science science
rational explanations not measurement
not numbers not equations that has
nothing to do with science that's has to
do with calculating with describing
because that's all that mathematical
physics does it describes and then it
has gives you an irrational explanation
for what it just described and yeah and
that's what an equation it's just a
description if you look at any equation
it doesn't explain anything I mean the
fact that I can tell you how fast or
what the acceleration of gravity is
doesn't tell me what causes gravity
which is what we're trying to find out
we we want a qualitative answer to that
question not a quantitative one and so
what these people do is you can say is
unscientific unscientific in the sense
that science is not about doing
equations it's not about doing
measurements science is about explaining
as it relates to physics is is about
explaining a mechanism if you haven't
explained a mechanism you are not a
physicist that's just that simple and
yeah a lot of people don't like that
because that's what they've been taught
for you know by rote in college and in
school and they've been taught that you
know science is about measurement about
numbers about equations and that's the
notion that's critical true why because
the mathematicians run the planet yeah
scientific world and so this is the
problem the problem is just people
absorb that it never question that you
know what do you mean you measure the
table and you did science you've got an
equation for for how fast the clock goes
around you know the big hand and small
hands so you got an equation that's
science just putting an equation and
then they also confuse technology you
know GPS they say Oh GPS proved general
relativity and you know what is it
time dilation proves special relativity
for quantum mechanics they say what's a
good one for quantum mechanics
oh yeah like that they say that they've
proven that a particle could be a two
places at once and and again it's just
an interpretation of what they did not
observe because they did not see it with
their eyes but see they talk about crew
about having proven all these things and
that technology somehow corroborates
that like they use the word quantum
computer there's a quantum computer
proved quantum theory no quantum
computing the word quantum means
ignorance that's what the word quantum
means okay every time you see the word
quantum it means ignorance so when you
have a component computer you have an
ignorance computer means that the guy
has no idea how it works at the at the
subatomic love all he knows is that it
does work because he developed them the
machine through trial and error he says
oh look we have a magnet here it
attracts another one there we can use it
for something he doesn't know how the
how the magnet attracted the other one
and he doesn't even care I mean because
he said I can't explain it but he can
use the technology so the technology
does not confirm that he's got a theory
for how a magnet attracts another in the
same way of GPS GPS does not confirm
relativity okay because what that would
mean is that GPS confirms that space is
warped and that time dilation occurs and
all this other nonsense created by
mathematical physics and the only thing
there is you have to explain it
rationally you have to explain it with
mechanisms and not just tell me that
time dilates that time stretches what do
you mean you know thanks try it what do
you mean a twin can be older in his
brother or much younger whatever you
know so so this what you got to explain
and when they give an irrational
interpretation they cannot say GPS
confirms it now it doesn't can run the
theory the physical interpretation okay
it might confirm the equations which is
the measurement that's different
it doesn't confirm the theory of the
explanation given for that phenomenon
that's the issue okay and then the last
comment here concerning energy a word
that I detest too my son asked me about
that I said I detest the word energy
okay I'm gonna find a useful definition
for energy energy the ability to cause
affects used in a sentence that baseball
had a lot of energy okay and what's my
argument there I'm saying the word
energy mass more than what it reveals
you know just the hide stuff from our
face from up from our eyes okay we use
the word energy and I've got a Korra
article it says energy means spirit the
old days they used to call it spirit now
we call it energy that's the only
difference the the word means exactly
the same as spirit in the old days a
concept such as the ability has no
muscle to cause effects on objects so if
if energy is the ability but I better
bro I don't care the ability has no I
can't transfer the ability to you you
know here catch my ability Dania I can't
move things with ability okay ability is
a concept if if the energy is a concept
you can't use it as a physical object
can't use it as a brick to break the
window like Felix did and again says the
baseball bat had a lot of energy does a
baseball bat possess energy like it
possesses a chunk of leather around it
you know it's like I explained to
someone now when you say I have a
headache is that the same thing as
saying I have ten cents in my pocket
a dime in my pocket so the word have is
is worrisome because the word have is
used in ordinary speech to relate to
objects and concepts and we don't have a
word that separates them then you know
that perfectly well okay and that's part
of the problem the word have that verb
is is a problem also people are not so
always aware of that and so like the
words mass time force charge wave and
field the word energy has no place in
science the word energy means spirit
every time you use the word energy
you're saying spirit that's what you pay
for every month to the utility company
for spirits yeah and we cannot explain a
single mechanism with these mathematical
concepts because concepts cannot be
placed on the screen to simulate a
phenomenon mechanism I cannot put the
word I cannot put energy on the screen
for you to understand what I'm talking
about
okay see if you could see energy on the
screen see okay I see energy there I see
how you transferred it
I see how it expanded I see how he got
shrunk and shrunk or whatever you do
something with it but you can't put
energy on the skin what are you gonna
put a little cloud of whatever spirit uh
you gonna put a little ghost there what
is energy
no one knows because no one has an ever
defined it okay and there are many
different definitions in fact of energy
and the one has nothing to do with the
other but none of them represent a
physical object you cannot draw a
picture of energy okay whatever you draw
is not what the other guy's gonna draw
you don't have a single meaning for the
world word energy okay let's move on to
mr. Tom st. Thomas Aquinas which I read
baptizes st. Thomas upon okay a quantum
why because the other day I put this up
here and said that Thomas invented
quantum mechanics this this is the 13th
century okay he says he asked these
questions okay and this is how he
phrased them he says whether a particle
is altogether incorporeal
whether a particle is composed of matter
in form whether the particles exist in
any great number whether the particles
different species whether there are
different types of particles right
whether a particle is in a place whether
it has location okay whether a particle
can be in several places at once
aha whether several particles can be at
the same time in the same place okay and
whether a particle passes through the
intermediate space okay and whether the
movement of part of a particle is
instantaneous these were the questions
that
st. Thomas a quantum you know ask the
about a thousand years ago it turns out
that he was really referring to this
okay now he didn't use the word particle
he used the word angel okay and so uh
yeah that's just wordy I guess you know
if if today we call them particles and
he called them angels okay I don't see
why he should not be given a retroactive
nobel prize for having discovered
quantum mechanics I think he he earned
it right and you can see this when we
put what how quantum deals with
particles today and here you have side
by side you know what quantum does you
know they asked the same questions or or
they dealt with the same subject matter
whether a party goes all together
incorporeal whether it's composed of
matter and form etc etc etc and so we go
down the line we find out that you know
we have the same issues today except
that we're not using acquaintances
angels what we're calling them as
particles but we're also giving them
these magic properties and let's see how
they match up I'll go one by one here
okay here's the first one and whether
particles all together in corporeal what
do you see in the literature in quantum
mechanics a particle is a concept it's
either an excited field charge waver
coal which is a wave packet or a small
localized object which is if you look at
the word object it's a collection of
matter a collection of matter is not a
physical object collection of matter is
known as a concept okay
collection of trees is a forest okay and
collection of people is people and a
collection of little kids is known as
children and so on you know collection
is a concept a physical objects is what
you can point to and draw on the board
and you know it's not made of parts yeah
that's called Mary ology anyways if you
can look at these on peril of famous
quantum mathematician in a tradition of
Saint Thomas a quantum says every part
of
actually a field haha the universe is
full of fields and what we think of as
particles are just excitations of those
fields like waves in an ocean an
electron for example is just an
excitation of an electron field so what
is a field well field is a concept
that's what it is field it's just a
bunch of numbers around an object it's a
strength or a weakness of could be a
magnetic field it could be an electric
field could be a gravitational field it
just says that as you get further and
further away from the main object the so
called field the numbers decrease the
strength of whatever's there decreases
that's all a field is in physical terms
and so to say that that a particle is
just a vibrating feel he hasn't said
anything charge electric charge is
carried by subatomic particles okay so
here we have a concept that is carried
by particles charge is quantized so it's
over here we have a discreet packet of
charge whatever this is the smallest
charge which can exist freely exists
freely that means it's a standalone
object right so please draw a charge for
me I need to see a picture what a charge
looks like if the charge is moving it
also generates a magnetic fields so that
if the charge moves that means it's a
physical object again we're treating
this concept as a physical object so is
is the charge incorporeal or not is an
excited field incorporeal or not and
then we have the famous wave achill with
the wave packet wave packed particle
duality is the concept that's a concept
not an object
so is it corporeal or incorporeal in
quantum mechanics that every particle or
quantum entity may be described as
either particle or a wave well if it's
described as a particle we can accept it
okay you can say for example you know
that you can drop a particle and say
look that's a particle and we can see it
we know what you're talking about please
draw a field what are you gonna draw
football field poppy field then you're
gonna draw charge what are you gonna
draw well these words are constant their
method
they have values attached to them
charges were at one point six times ten
to the nine minus nineteen coulombs
that's a measure of something right
we're not talking about a physical
standalone object we're talking about a
number and that represents charge but
these people talk about the charge
moving so are particles in corporeal or
are they you know there it is again
or are they concepts this is what we
need to figure out okay so so there is
no difference in the way Saint Thomas
used angels and quantum mechanics uses
so-called particles okay with which they
claim to interpret the physical world
around us okay here's a no wrong one
that's given here got so many of these
sometimes hard to get them up there okay
yeah let's go with the second issue
their area says whether a particle is
composed of matter in form let's see
what quantum says the survey says poor
particle what is a point particle an
idealization of particles heavily used
in physics heavily used okay in physics
I don't know it's tough it's defining
feature is that it lacks spatial
extension okay being zero dimensional it
does not take up space so what is it
made out of what is what kind of matter
what kind of form does it have looks
like none okay and that's what quantum
answers
how about mass a point mass meaning a
point particle with a nonzero mass and
no other properties or structure so what
are quantum particles made of well I
guess they're not made of much they're
made of all this concepts mathematical
car their quantities that's what they
are they're mathematical concepts
quantities no difference between the
angel and the particles of quantum so
far
the descriptions that st. Thomas a
quantum gave gave the Angels applies
just as well to every particle of
quantum mechanics that the concepts the
notions have not changed in a thousand
years or they've been resuscitated you
could say okay by people like Bohr and
Rutherford okay let's look at the next
one okay it says whether they're
particles exist in great numbers well
you look up the Dirac sea a theoretical
model of the vacuum as an infinite sea
of particles sounds familiar
QED vacuum is a state with no matter
particles and no photons QED vacuum
contains vacuum fluctuations aha virtual
particles that pop into and out of
existence and a finite energy called
vacuum energy so it's got no particles
no photons whatever those are and but it
does have virtual particle particles
that come in through the magic wand of
God I guess you know and whatever vacuum
energy is and what did we decide energy
was absolutely nothing it's a concept so
the vacuum this vacuum QED vacuum is
made of virtual particles and magical
particles and a concept called
vacuum energy so we've got lots of that
I guess that's infinite right you can
create as many miraculous or magical
particles as you want and says it juicy
multiple vacuum states exist okay so is
it infinite yeah I guess
the quantum mathematician would say it's
infinite they like the word infinite
because it eliminates all questions see
if they said it's finite people say well
what's outside of it and so they said
not Symphony an infinite can mean
structural or County you know and they
usually refer to counting they say you
can count forever and you'll never count
the last one so to speak and that's
called infinite it's not infinite really
we call it incessant in science not
infinite
let's go with the next one and there it
is but they're particles different
species well you have the standard model
of quantum mechanics and yeah it's all
these particles supposedly are different
but see the problem here is that quantum
mechanics predicts to use their term
predicts that there should be in a
single particle at the end of the yellow
brick road
you can continue chopping a particle in
half and arrive at nothing as Democritus
and Lucinda tsipras said you know over
two thousand years ago
you can't continue chopping something
and end up with absolutely nothing you
at some point you got to end up with
something and so the the assumptions of
quantum mechanics already include the
fact that there is one particle that
underlies at all
and so you know you can't escape that in
quantum mechanics so be aware that
quantum mechanics does predict a single
particle at the end of the yellow brick
road okay and whether a particle is in a
place okay yeah says the electron is
everywhere okay so I guess it's like God
all particles are actually excited
fields okay what is a field of regional
or space in which a given effects such
as magnetism exist that's one definition
in one dictionary another dictionary
says the influence of some agent as
electricity or gravitation considered as
existing at all points in space and it
says fields extend to infinity okay so
what's the answer to whether particle is
in a place well it's like god we had
that a minute ago the particle is
everywhere and that solves all questions
you know the reporters have no more
questions after that because the
particle is everywhere so okay so that
answered your question okay
okay here's another one this is from mr.
Victor Toth he's a guy who writes in
Cora a bunch of nonsense that he writes
on behalf of the establishment he's as a
standard model of particle physics of
quantum field physics it's fundamental
objects are all fields okay so we have
fields which are concepts that's that's
the bread and butter that's the building
block this theory has two fundamental
objects the electromagnetic field and
the electron field so we have fields and
fields and fields we have poppy fields
corn fields wheat fields you know and
that's it these fields are functions of
space-time coordinates
what does coordinate have to do with a
standalone object I have no idea these
fields are present everywhere sounds
familiar there's like God right is there
everywhere these fields are quantum
fields ok when they interact that means
that we're talking about fields
interacting that means they're talking
about an object quickly he switched over
to physical object arted as a concept
and now he moves into objects he says
they interact they exchange energy ok we
so they exchanged this this ghost this
thing they call energy whatever energy
is please draw it on the board so I know
what they exchanged ok and momentum
another concept these units of
excitation have a distinct existence
how can excitation be have existence
what has existence if you define the
word exist is an object that has
location that's what has existence you
cannot say the excitation or the fields
or the momentum or the energy exists
because those are concepts concepts do
not exist in physics ok and these unit
excitations are are particles that's
what they call particles these
excitations of fields of whatever there
you got in there
these units of excitations do not
necessarily have a specific location no
kidding
how can they if there are concepts they
are not miniature cannonballs ok so
there he's accepting that
you know we're not talking about
particles
you know corpuscles what everybody
understands by the word particle they're
saying that this is a concepts a
vibrating field in a field is a concept
so what you have is a vibrating number
bunch of units that's what's migrating
the excitations of the electromagnetic
field or the electron field are not
spatially localized of course they
cannot be they are indeed everywhere so
yeah that's how they get you off their
back it's everywhere yeah you understood
okay
the natural state of these excitations
is that they are spread out in space
okay now does that answer your questions
do you still have any questions after
that I mean he answered all the
questions just says it's everywhere it's
nowhere and some concept that vibrates
did you understand so this is the
problem problem is quantum mechanics has
no answers they're giving the same
answers that mr. Tommy gave us a
thousand years ago for angels exactly
the same once you know and here is uh
here is uh the issue the next two issues
whether a particle can be in several
places at once
quantum calls it decoherence and whether
several particles can be at the same
time at the same place we have
superposition okay and they intermingle
these as well okay so what are what are
they talking about what is this what is
this superposition and decoherence well
fortunately we have a little gift that
we can show you and this is not for me
this is from them okay he's just so you
know here it is
okay and they tell you this in your face
okay quantum physics you know we can
have these two things we can have a part
of them to be in two positions at the
same time and an atom can be excited not
excited at the same time so we have yes
or no and maybe as well so we've covered
every base so that you don't ask any
more questions okay we have answers for
everything because you know they make no
sense that's why yeah so so keep in mind
that the answers the replies the
physical interpretations that quantum
mechanics gives you are nonsense they're
just as much nonsense
as Tommy is angels so don't laugh at
Tommy okay he didn't he was there you
know thousand years ago he has an excuse
what's the excuse of all these bozos
okay that they claim that you know
particles are everywhere in their
vibrations of fields and whatever okay
and here's a Tommy's tunneling how a
particle goes in his case it was an
angel goes from one place to another he
goes from A to C without passing through
B that was the issue that st. Thomas
quantum tried to explain okay
and here's today how we do that we do
the same thing in quantum mechanics
today and here it is the answer whether
particle passes through intermediate
space according to quantized from a site
okay according to quantum mechanics the
ball has a wave function and this
function is defined over all space there
is always a chance that as the ball
encounters the hill the ball will
suddenly be found beyond it a part of
the wave packet representing an incident
quantum particle can filter through the
barrier boundary and eventually perish
after travelling some distance outside
the barrier what these people have
invented is a mechanism even caught on
mechanism you know let me get this thing
out of there but these people haven't
been as a mechanism where they say look
what you have is this this is the notion
you have to keep in mind they say a
particle is only detected at emission
and a detection act at the reception
okay in between it travels as a wave
okay you got that so the only way we can
detect it is not as a way because the
wave function collapses and turns into a
particle that's the notion you have to
have in mind so you have this particle
starts out there as a particle but he
meet it he turns into a way for who
knows what reason
it's the wave that travels through the
air and that's you know you know you
have James Maxwell saying yeah it's a
transverse wave okay he he
mathematically described it okay with
his equations
and now what happens when it reaches the
other end the only way you can detect it
is when it again condenses suddenly for
no reason whatsoever into a particle
okay so suddenly the wavefunction
collapses and turns into a particle but
what happens if you put a barrier well
they're saying that the way it doesn't
delay it appears on the other side
instantly as if the part of the barrier
wasn't there so yeah just like mr. Tommy
here you know Tommy a quantum he said
you know they say the quantum says you
know particles appear on the other side
instantaneously like it did go through
the intermediate space okay so we have
the same notion then that good old
Thomas a quantum and a thousand years
ago okay and there's one more if I can
get this thing up there and that's
whether a movement of a particle is
instantaneous which is more or less the
same thing with the intermediate space
because they're related and we have this
again entanglement and and tunneling all
in one where you know a particle effects
another one instantaneously and a
particle goes through a barrier
instantaneously so so the notions are
still there you know does particle go
through from A to C and does it pass
through B that's one issue and does a
particle affect another one
instantaneously okay and yeah the only
thing that the quantum mathematician has
to answer is what do you mean ISM you
know what is the mechanism for that to
happen please explain the mechanism and
we'll understand
and right now they have no explanation
for this what they're doing is
introducing ghosts and spirits in
between they're just doing it with magic
and they have no rational explanations
and of course the irrational individual
out there the lay man so there's
something wrong here of course something
is wrong
you won't understand quantum mechanics
you won't understand general relativity
because they're in the business of
moving concepts which is what Tommy did
you know Saint Thomas Aquinas he
the same thing a thousand years ago he
was talking about angel spirits and he
justified him and he said you know angel
has all these super powers because they
were ordained by God so what's changed
what's different in quantum mechanics
what's different in general relativity
that is different from that and you
won't find any difference as you can see
all those concepts that st. Thomas a
quantum had a thousand years ago were
either reinvented or applied to
particles of quantum mechanics every
single one of them and so whenever you
hear something like that it sounds
irrational to you it because it is
irrational because they're moving
concepts okay anyways I'm gonna finish
up with mr. st. Thomas Aquinas and what
is it Wednesday and will continue with
geometry we're trying to figure out what
this especially what the point is we got
this point particle and somehow that
point particle turned into a line and
the line is not a line line is distance
a line is motion displacement a line is
time it's everything except the line and
you wonder what all those things have to
do with geometry okay and this is this
is where how we got into aquinas because
aquinas doesn't and analysis of that
primarily for the purposes of time he's
trying to figure out God basically how
God knows all of time where his outside
of time and so for him all exist
simultaneously the BOK the universe so
to speak another the thing that we
borrowed from from him and if we have
this block universe that means God if
he's omniscient he knows already what
you're gonna do tomorrow and if he knows
that I'm gonna move my right hand next
or my left hand next I hope I'm doing
the right hands here if he God knows
that I had no free will and this is what
troubled them this is the issue that
they were trying to figure out because
it's you know God can't be omniscient
and also give allow you to have free
will
and all these religious folks they don't
understand they try to accommodate free
will with with emissions and this is
where you know where st. Thomas Aquinas
got involved with geometry and he of
course he's gonna introduce the point
and a line and just like Aristotle and
Euclid didn't reform okay so where I
continue with these subjects on
Wednesday if you're interested in them
pop your head in here and you'll hear a
different version of science that you'll
hear from then you'll hear from
mathematical physics
we'll see you that bye-bye